bonjour bonjour
vous allez bien parce que vous avez été
élu dimanche et oui donc j'imagine que
forcément vous allez bien rééduc député
la France insoumise de la
Seine-Saint-Denis on le précise et on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane
bonjour bonjour on va évidemment
commencer par les législatives et vous
avez sans doute entendu Emmanuel Macron
hier sur le tarmac de l'aéroport avant
de s'envoler vers la Roumanie appelé les
Français à lui donner une majorité
solide est-ce que c'est important pour
la majorité du pays que le président
dispose d'une majorité solide et d'une
majorité absolue non moi je fais le vœu
qui est une majorité solide qui se
dégage pour qu'en gouvernement puisse
agir après c'est aux Français de décider
si c'est de le programme d'Emmanuel
Macron ou notre programme il y a pas en
cinquième république une espèce
d'argument d'autorité parce qu'on a élu
Emmanuel Macron d'un seul coup on doit
abandonner ses convictions et uniquement
se réduire au rôle de le fan club de
Monsieur Macron qui doit venir dimanche
prochain et pas voter en conscience
alors moi j'ai trouvé que son interview
déjà elle était bizarre en terme de
communication je sais pas si une
imitation Donald Trump sur le tarmac
avec un avion derrière pas aimé le rond
des moteurs derrière non c'est un peu
bizarre et ce qui s'en va il prend la
fuite comme Michel Sardou se mélange je
m'en vais je sais pas très bien ce qu'il
veut dire et surtout il a il a il a un
argument pardon qui moi m'a piqué c'est
à dire qui dit en gros le seul vote pour
sauver la République c'est le sien alors
ça c'est pas aucune voix d'un manque à
la répétition
si je suis bon prince je peux dire
peut-être qu'il invite tes pensées aller
voter très bien il faut aller voter et
je forme le vœu c'était ça aussi ça il
ressemble si c'est le cas un électeur
sur deux n'est pas venu voter dimanche
le souverain c'est le peuple il doit se
déplacer je les invite à aller voter
quel que soit pour le candidat qui
choisiront aller voter parce que c'est
plus important je dirais dans certains
produits que l'élection présidentielle
la majorité vient sortira mais comme
quand même si on suit le propose que
nous dit Emmanuel Macron j'ai compris la
tactique elle est grossière parfois la
part de ses amis les extraits arrivent
au secours aucun programme n'est Rais à
part le sien Mélenchon est un personnage
totalement qui va mettre le pays sans
dessus dessous on va apprendre bientôt
qui mange des petits enfants au petit
déjeuner etc enfin on rivalise
d'arguments absurde monsieur Castaner
ayant le pompon que si la nuit Pesse
était lui on pourra plus couper du bois
dans son jardin enfin n'importe quoi
tout y passe j'ai vu madame de mon
Chalin expliqué elle est face à un
monsieur que vous connaissez Jérôme
Guedj c'est-à-dire qu'il vend la traiter
qu'il aurait des relents d'antisémitisme
alors pardon mais je regrette j'ai
attaché à la laïcité mais par son
histoire personnelle attaquer Jérôme
Guedj sur le terrain de soi-disant
l'antisémitisme c'est c'est absurde
c'est c'est flétrissant
un peu fort ce matin dans le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France il dit le chaos
c'est Emmanuel Macron est-ce que là
aussi c'est pas un peu gros bah déjà il
répondait à ce tapis de bombe que nous
recevons et le cas oui c'est à l'heure
actuelle quand vous avez un million de
personnes supplémentaires qui sont
passées sous le seuil de pauvreté nous
dit l'INSEE en 5 ans on est passé de 9,4
millions à 10,5 c'est-à-dire
millions de gens sous le seuil de
pauvreté et qu'en même temps je fais ça
je simplifie vous avez les cinq
personnes les plus riches du pays qui
possèdent désormais autant que 40% la
population soit 27 millions de personnes
ce pays qui se fracture avec des gens
qui accumulent des richesses d'un côté
et des milieux populaires en difficulté
en raison de l'inflation des gens qui
basculent sous le seuil de pauvreté on
peut imaginer autre chose voilà ce que
nous disons et on voit bien que notre
programme il est caricaturé salut
ridiculiser de la part de certains mais
en même temps l'événement pardon de le
dire qui s'est passé dimanche c'est que
beaucoup de gens sont venus voter et que
nous sommes aujourd'hui les électeurs en
transformé monstres mais dans la
possibilité de gagner et de voir
Mélenchon du vote dimanche bof bof bof
c'est quand même un record absolu en
matière d'abstention
quand vous dites qu'on a besoin d'une
majorité solide alors qu'elle soit
ensemble ou une peste etc la démocratie
a besoin d'une majorité solide qui soit
basée sur une très forte participation
sinon il y a une suspicion ou un
discours qui peut se développer autour
de la légitimité bien sûr de
parlementaires qui serait mal élu
c'était le discours en 2017 est-ce que
en 2022 vous pourriez avoir une majorité
avec le même type de discours en disant
finalement la nuit pèse est majoritaire
ou très bien placé à l'Assemblée mais
avec des députés qui ont été désignés
par une toute petite partie une toute
petite fraction de la population moi je
lâcherai jamais ce discours que j'ai
tenu que j'ai tenu publiquement que j'ai
même dû sur votre plateau
bien sûr nous avons un problème c'est
possible vous pensez que c'est encore
possible il faut oui oui ça va se jouer
à ça comment on fait parce qu'en général
le deuxième tour m'inviter moi j'ai pas
d'autres moyens qui est là ça se termine
vendredi à minuit c'est à dire que mes
amis sont et là si toutes les missions
est terminée je vais aider d'autres amis
qui sont en campagne faire campagne pour
ta porte collage d'affiche diffusion
track des émissions vous faites bien le
job si je peux me permettre mais je veux
dire je n'aurais apprécié que le
gouvernement madame borne accepte un
débat dans une grande chaîne pour dire
voilà on discute programme contre
programme on a vu quand même que parmi
les stratégies d'Emmanuel Macron c'était
quand même discret quoi je veux dire une
volonté
un peu triviale il pensait que en
faisant profil bas on nomme la Premier
ministre le plus tard possible sitôt
qu'elle est élu on nous explique que
désormais des ministres ont le devoir de
réserve parce que la campagne commence
on on dit uniquement voilà vous m'avez
lu donc donnez-moi une majorité braves
gens et restons-en là il n'avait pas
prévu et je vais vous faire une
confidence nous non plus qu'on arrive au
lendemain de la présidentielle a réunir
cette nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et il y a eu un
tournant stratégique qui conclut de
notre part qu'on a pu réaliser que sans
aucun doute Emmanuel Macron là encore a
été un peu déstabilisé en disant mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est Mélenchon
enfin un gros score mais en plus il
rassemble des forces ils ont un
programme 640 propositions j'ai envie
d'aller lire des candidats un discours
ils nous ont accusé d'incohérence mais
quand même globalement les Français ont
vu que nous avions une parole commune
avec Olivier Faure Julien Bayou etc et
que ça valait le coup alors après ce que
vous dites et j'en termine là-dessus
c'est évident que il faut réformer nos
institutions et ça chacun que nous
portons cela moi je suis pour une
sixième république comment il y a de la
proportionnelle comment il y a la prise
en compte du vote blanc comment le
citoyen a des droits nouveaux aussi pour
contrôler ses élus que ce soit par des
référents initiatives citoyens à titre
personnel je suis quelqu'un de favorable
à l'idée qu'on puisse révoquer des élus
en cours de mandat ça c'est des idées
fortes on a le droit de pas être
d'accord mais je dis à tout le monde ce
qui nous écoute que vous soyez pour
Monsieur Macron Madame Le Pen qu'importe
une démocratie ou à force celui qui est
élu et qui concentre énormément de
pouvoir comme le président de la
République repose sur une tête d'épingle
à l'arrivée celle qui te fait 24 % des
exprimés 18% des inscrits au premier
tour il est élu essentiellement dans un
rejet de Madame Le Pen enfin attention
parce que ça ça ouvre quoi comme
possibilité que les Français les
Françaises pensent que tout ça ne sert
plus à rien que les élus ne les
représentent pas et la solution
autoritaire ou la tentative on peut la
tentation on va dire autoritaire peut
l'emporter et moi je ne le souhaite pas
parce qu'un grand pays ne se dirige pas
vous redoutez ce qui peut se passer dans
ce dans ce quinquennat
que les gilets jaunes des mouvements de
colère l'idée après tout même que ce qui
est un peu le foyer intellectuel de
l'extrême droite qu'il faut quelqu'un
d'autoritaire qui prenne le contrôle du
pays parce que c'est comme ça qu'on va
s'en sortir mais est-ce que vous-même en
disant que la bataille doit se
poursuivre dans la rue même après les
élections vous encouragez pas aussi un
peu à ce type de mouvement non attendez
que je sois clair quand on dit qu'il
faut se mobiliser qu'il faut qu'il y a
des grèves que les organisations
syndicales soient là quand on nous dit
que ça va être la retraite à 65 ans je
forme le veut que le mouvement syndical
mais ça c'est notre histoire bon sang on
va pas quand même découvrir qu'on dans
ce pays déjà il y a un peuple turbulent
qui a la passion de l'égalité et que si
il y a une volonté de faire travailler
le monde du travail pendant longtemps
moi je suis profondément attaché à la
démocratie que les choses soient claires
qu'ils soient dimanche
même si Jean-Luc Mélenchon devient pas
Premier ministre mais qu'est-ce que je
ne m'appelle pas Donald Trump et
j'invite pas les gens à prendre le
Capitole de force façon c'est absurde
c'est pas ça la discussion par contre je
continue à questionner ce que j'ai dit
c'est comme président en 5e République
qui s'en est institution particulière
dans notre histoire une concentration
pouvoir sur un homme qui a une base
électorale aussi faible pose un problème
et le président dans le comprendre et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon si lui tu étais
président il avait toujours dit que
l'Assemblée constituante le fait que
notre peuple rediscute quels sont nos
institutions pourquoi nous voulons vivre
ensemble pourquoi vous et moi nous tous
Comment on fait pop sur la base de quel
droit quel contrôle des élus c'est
passionnant ça sinon attention à cet
égard si vous arriviez si on arrivait
dimanche à une majorité relative pour la
majorité présidentielle c'est-à-dire pas
de majorité absolue moins de 289 sièges
pour la République en marche le modem et
horizon est-ce que ça ce serait
l'objectif serait accompli atteint
est-ce que ce serait une victoire pour
pour la nuque est-ce que ça permettrait
aussi
après ce que vous venez de dire de
renforcer les pouvoirs du Parlement et
de refaire que le Parlement soit à
nouveau un petit peu intéressant et que
les débats ils soient plus musclés je
partage mon but dans la vie c'est pas
d'être notre but pardon c'est pas d'être
le poêle à gratter enfin c'est de avoir
une majorité mais si elle n'a pas lu
alors vous y croyez encore sur
est-ce que sincèrement vous pensez
encore être en capacité et j'ai envie de
chacun à ne pas avoir d'arguments
d'autorité je ne dis pas que c'est fait
mais j'aime pas les arbres c'est à dire
mais monsieur Corbières allons ce n'est
pas possible je ne sais pas un Français
surdenais pas mieux voter dimanche ils
vont se déplacer dimanche prochain je ne
sais ayant l'honnêteté et la modestie
dire c'est les Français qui vont juger
mais pas d'argument d'autorité comme
certains veulent le dire vous êtes
signés parce que vous savez que vous
gagnerez pas non j'y crois alors
deuxièmement vous dites autre chose
c'est que
pardon j'ai perdu le fils aucune
majorité relative voilà ça relance le
Parlement moi j'avoue les Français et
les Françaises qui nous regardent
écoutez c'est bien ce que tu es en train
d'avoir lieu il faut repart le
mentariser la vie politique et je le dis
ici dans la maison du Sénat moi qui suis
aussi attaché à l'Assemblée nationale il
est sain quand pouvoir politique soit
entre les mains de 577 personnes pour ce
qui est l'assemblée plutôt que une seule
voilà on va discuter il y aura de la
controverse il y aura des commissions il
y aura du regard collectif c'est bon
pour notre vie politique on ne dirige
pas un grand pays avec un seul homme
avec tel que le cas dernièrement un
petit groupe autour du prénom République
pour gérer la crise sur le covidence
la question est-ce que vous pourriez sur
certains textes votés avec avec la
République en marche et avec la majorité
présidentielle il y a un son tendu dans
la question moi je suis un homme de
conviction je voterai pour ce qui me
semble bon pour les gens pas jouer
est-ce que je veux dire c'est je suis
pas dans l'opposition systématique mais
si vous me présentez que des textes que
je jure agressif je voterai la retraite
à 65 ans
parlons concrètement c'est à dire que
souvent vous savez les macronistes
parfois ils mettent des têtes de
chapitres et Lisa vous êtes contre mais
moi je demande à voir dans le texte ils
ont une tendance à utiliser et on pourra
en parler un vocabulaire pour dire qui
qui prend une forme de l'inverse de ce
qu'il y a dedans qui est pas bon et
d'ailleurs la question des mots elle est
importante j'ai dit tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui j'entends dire faudrait
faire des barrages républicains comme
Madame Rachel kéké femme de ménage va
être élu on utilise ce vocabulaire chez
les macronistes j'ai dit qu'ils
utilisent le mouvement qui est son
adversaire qui appelle à voter pour elle
non
mais elle a le droit d'appeler à voter
pour elle c'est le le le comment dire le
lot de tout candidat mais on n'est pas
obligé d'utiliser le terme de barrage
républicain ça moi je suis prof
d'histoire attention je veux dire c'est
les années 30 contre l'extrême droite
c'est 1956 contre le mouvement
poujadiste on n'utilise pas ce
vocabulaire contre une femme de ménage
qui peut-être va être élu que je
trouverai formidable on a le droit elle
a le droit de défendre son projet mais
pas d'utiliser tout ce vocabulaire
politique pour le transformer autre
chose si les mots n'ont plus aucun sens
on pourra plus parler
est-ce que vous clairement vous appelez
à voter pour Emmanuel Macron enfin pour
les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle dans les circonscriptions
vous êtes absent
non attendez je pardon je non
il faut voter pour le changement
toujours dit pas une voix pour l'extrême
droite donc une voix pour ensemble il y
a des électeurs qui auront du mal
parfois se déplacer il y en a d'autres
qui font le bulletin pour battre à
l'extérieur
non non je dis pas abstention je dis pas
une voix pour le FN et après des
lecteurs fait ce qu'il veut j'ai des
amis qui ont sur cette question là des
opinions différentes et je crois qu'il
faut pas comment dirais-je nous diviser
artificiellement sur cette question
voilà je j'observe que par ailleurs pour
ce qui est des macronistes après nous
avoir fait des grandes leçons contre
l'extrême droite ils n'ont pas la même
clarté et même parfois il nous renvoie
Michel Blanquer a dit clairement que
nous pour lui nous sommes la même chose
que l'extrême droite cet homme a non
seulement été battu dans les urnes et il
revient pour dire facilement sale
personnage monsieur Blanquer il ne
sonore pas il y en a d'autres comme ça
moi j'ai pas entendu quand nous sommes
dans des duels face à l'extrême droite
la macronie j'ai entendu des voix mais
pas clairement un discours consiste à
dire qu'il fallait battre l'extrême
droite et voter
tu as une voix elle ne doit aller à
l'extrême droite Olivia Grégoire a dit
pas une voix ne doit aller mieux le
borne que moi parce que moi je l'ai
entendu parler des extrêmes mais je mets
j'ai aussi je me donne le point c'est
maintenant qu'il y avait raison je sais
parce que il y a quand même il y a une
triangulaire parce que là aussi il y a
des cas intéressants chez vous il y a
une triangulaire notamment dans la
Nièvre ou la candidate de la nuque qui
est la France insoumise est arrivée
troisième et elle a refusé de se retirer
alors que c'est le rassemblement
national qui est arrivé en tête est-ce
que vous la soutenez encore cette
candidate moi je crois que ce que j'ai
vu c'est assez ouvert surtout que il y a
des macronistes qui ne se retirent pas
non plus dans certains endroits donc il
y a une circonscription aussi dans
l'intégrale mais bon est-ce que vous
soutenez le fait que malgré le fait que
le rassemblement national soit par
exemple
mes amis ont dû apprécier le fait que ça
ne favorisait pas nécessairement
l'extrême droite et qu'il y avait un
deuxième tour qui méritait d'être porté
juste avant pour revenir sur l'idée de
d'une assemblée dans laquelle la
majorité présidentielle n'aurait pas la
majorité absolue excusez-moi je
j'insiste mais ça voudrait dire que vous
seriez votre groupe la nuque serait le
premier groupe ou premier intergroupe
d'opposition
et donc vous auriez un rôle d'arbitrage
très fort et que dans cette perspective
là il y a un stand de texte qui pourrait
être négocié pied à pied avec chaque
composante des groupes est-ce que ça
c'est pas un risque de voir votre
coalition la nouvelle union populaire
exploser très vite et se diviser très
vite au sein de l'Assemblée sur les sur
des textes avec des écologistes qui
diraient oui au gouvernement pas vous et
puis inversement sur d'autres textes
des dividendes divergences de vue avec
les communistes les socialistes vous
savez elle va être autrement dit elle va
durer cette nouvelle union populaire au
sein de l'Assemblée ou pas
moi je dirais que c'est comme le vélo ça
tient debout tant que ça avance si si on
vous fait rire mais tant que c'est une
belle image non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que si cette coalition apparaît
comme on dynamique en capacité de
prendre le pouvoir prochainement qu'on
est qu'on a raté la victoire de peu etc
et qu'un intérêt à maintenir je suis
persuadé que toutes les composantes de
la nouvelle-union populaire souvent les
conditions pour que l'assurance
futés que les autres composants est-ce
que du coup vous allez être vraiment
enclin à faire des compromis oui non moi
je pense qu'il faut que ce que nous
avons fait là je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un tournant stratégique depuis
l'élection présidentielle et je pense
que nous l'avons fait et il a c'est un
tournant qui qui ne va pas s'arrêter au
lendemain de l'élection de toute manière
donc on va être contraint et c'est pas
qu'une contrainte d'ailleurs de discuter
politiquement moi ce que vous dites
c'est une hypothèse mais je ne crois pas
que mes amis socialistes j'y mets le
mois a mis entre guillemets parce que
parfois on sait un peu confronté mais
malgré tout on s'est découvert aussi moi
j'ai apprécié Olivier fond dans cette
campagne qui est un homme de qualité bon
je ne crois pas que nos amis socialistes
voient leur rôle désormais pour être le
supplétif de Macron pour mettre en place
des textes moi je pense que la tendance
de ce que vous décrivez mais là tous les
deux on fait des hypothèses c'est plutôt
que le groupe LR risquent d'être absorbé
de plus en plus dans la majorité
macroniste parce que c'est la logique
des choses c'est plutôt ça qui va avoir
lieu et quelque part pour ceux qui
s'intéressent aux idées politiques la
disparition de ce qui était la droite
traditionnel qui va
le macronisme va devenir le grand parti
de droite et du centre à mon avis on
pourrait voir la disparaître les
républicains ou voilà au moins
c'est plutôt ça que je vois d'autant que
les républicains à ce stade n'ont pas la
personnalité ça compte chez eux qui
pourraient être le candidat à la
prochaine élection présidentielle donc
on voit bien mais en même temps là
encore je veux pas être trop long depuis
la deuxième élection d'Emmanuel Macron
j'ai envie de dire quelque part Macron
c'est fini et déjà des gens se disent
qui sera le candidat en 2027 donc on va
avoir beaucoup de rivalité pour savoir
qui est la première la prochaine
championne du champion parler vous
parlez vous parlez de personnalité il en
faut dans l'hémicycle c'est pas un petit
c'est pas c'est pas un petit peu
couillon que Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit pas
représenté au législatives
d'accord mais il va vous manquer quand
même non on connaît son côté triba
orateur il va il était moteur à
l'Assemblée il va me manquer parce que
ça va faire plus de 25 ans que je fais
la politique avec lui mais il s'en va
pas et je veux dire il n'est pas comme
ça
on fait une erreur de ne pas se
représenter à la députation je crois pas
parce que vous savez un homme comme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un intellectuel
en politique donc qui crient des livres
donc qui fait des discours qui fait des
conférences je suis persuadé que vous
aurez toujours à coeur de l'inviter s'il
y a quelque chose à dire parce qu'il est
comment dire c'est une parole politique
forte et quelque part le pari qui fait
pour le moment il est tout entier tendu
vers l'objectif d'être Premier ministre
pardon mais je vais le faire sans
signalisme etc comme il l'a dit il a
quand même de nombreuses années de
parlementaires il connaît le job il sait
ce que c'est il pense aussi que
peut-être s'il est pas là et il a bien
raison ça fera émerger encore plus fort
toute une série de personnalités
politiques parmi nous c'est la politique
et est-ce que vous avez envie de devenir
le leader de la France insoumise là-bas
comme beaucoup de mes amis de jouer en
rôle important comment dire je l'ai dit
j'ai une fidélité à SCA représenté
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le mélange chenille
d'un discours républicain social laïque
attaché effectivement aujourd'hui à la
compréhension de l'exigence de la cause
écologique etc il va avoir une
concurrence entre vous quatrième case
avec
de talents extrêmement fort tout le
monde l'a remarqué et moi c'est un ami
très cher il y a aussi des personnalités
féminines qui qui sont de grands talents
tout ça on va analyser la situation on a
trois ans je crois entre l'élection qui
se termine dimanche prochain et la
prochaine donc on va débattre évidemment
entre nous un peu moins 2024 les
européennes on n'est pas immédiatement
surplombé par une échéance électorale
donc on va débattre et il faut qu'on
voit moi j'ai ce que je veux dire c'est
il faut d'abord qu'on voit comment on
analyse qui s'est passé est-ce qu'on a
gagné ce qu'on a pas gagné pour qu'on a
pas gagné comment en gros je le fais
simple on a bien vu qu'il y a des
quartiers populaires des lieux urbains
ont fait des gros scores et des milieux
ruraux où il faut progresser comment on
fait moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse quelle
ligne politique permet de ne pas perdre
ce que nous avons acquis et de faire
venir à nous des gens si la discussion
politique a lieu et qu'elle est fertile
après on verra qu'il incarne voilà c'est
tout et si on fait ça bien bah c'est
formidable problème
est caricaturé alors il pose des
questions notamment sur son financement
et vous entendez évidemment les
oppositions les poser 250 milliards de
dépenses nouvelles vous vous parlez de
révolution fiscale pour les financer ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que quand on
est républicain vous savez on est un
partageot aussi quelque part et que le
seul outil que je connaisse qui est
démocratique c'est l'impôt voilà et que
l'emploi actuellement il est plutôt
injustif il fait concentré beaucoup de
choses sur les classes moyennes et nous
nous proposons 14 tranches d'impôts
notamment et ceux qui sont les plus
fortunés selon effectivement indiscute
avant 100 milliards beaucoup plus
supplémentaires mais qui reposeront sur
qui uniquement sur les plus forts
pour tout le monde c'est ce que proposer
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la présidentielle
quand vous avez les 500 personnes les
plus fortunés de ce pays qui ont vu leur
fortune personnelle passer en 5 ans de
570 milliards à 1000 milliards il y a
quand même là une marge dans lequel oui
il faut contribuer à
non mais ça suffira pour les personnes
les plus fortunées qui peuvent financer
ces dépenses supplémentaires
qui ont fait des profits de manière
insolente et que il est bon que ce soit
remis aussi dans le circuit économique
nous allons aussi notre Paris c'est de
une relance par la consommation
populaire et par l'augmentation des
salaires pour relancer la machine tout
ça permet mis bout à bout d'avoir des
difficultés
le blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité est une réponse à ça
est-ce que vous savez qu'actuellement
c'est ils font essentiellement un effet
spéculatif la montée des prix ça n'est
pas dû aux conséquences directes de la
guerre en Ukraine l'argument un peu
facile donc tous ces aspects là il y a
je veux dire ce qui permet que notre
tissu économique petite entreprise
commerçants artisan puisse fonctionner
c'est qu'il y ait de la consommation
populaire de soyons clairs
pour tout le monde avec votre programme
non alors dans des proportions
différentes évidemment
on fait des différents simulateurs à
ceux qui gagnent 4000 euros
individuellement il y aura moins
d'impôts qui seront payés mais après un
discute avant pour les gens les plus
fortunés il y aura une participation une
sollicitation plus significative le
rattrapage des salaires que vous évoquez
il est salutaire il est indispensable le
problème c'est est-ce que les
entreprises sont en capacité de
d'encaisser ça aujourd'hui dans le le
texte actuel et notamment les petites
entreprises est-ce qu'elles peuvent
augmenter leurs salariés sans sans
mettre leur équilibre en danger bien il
le faut bien sûr on va les aider à faire
roux l'autre jour dire un boulanger si
on augmente Facebook je mets la clé sous
la porte à tout le monde le swing à 1300
€ 200 € par mois d'augmentation faut pas
non plus faire croire que immédiatement
toutes les entreprises vont vont fermer
il y a quand même beaucoup de groupes y
compris des groupes significatifs qui
peuvent les grands groupes mais vous
avez beaucoup de petit nous avons aussi
dans notre programme
nous avons dans le programme une
sollicitation fiscale plus importante
pour les grands groupes qui peut
permettre de la redistribution sur les
petites entreprises et les moyennes
entreprises vous savez beaucoup de gens
sont très inquiets de la situation des
petites entreprises mais actuellement
vous avez beaucoup de petites boîtes qui
travaillent pour des grands groupes qui
les maltraite donc moi je suis très
attentif à ce que les petits patrons
commerçants artisans soit aider mais ils
sont aidé si la s'il y a de la
consommation populaire pas des grands
groupes qui captent des richesses et
notamment aussi par des aides publiques
qui ne sont pas utiles à l'intérêt
général la dernière question sur un
autre sujet avec vous qui avez été élu
en Seine-Saint-Denis les sénateurs
poursuivent jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
leurs auditions sur le fiasco de la
finale de la Ligue des champions au
Stade de France est-ce que vous
souhaitez dans la nouvelle Assemblée
qu'il y a une commission d'enquête nous
l'avons dit nous souhaitons qu'elle ait
lieu gloire au sénateur j'ai envie de
dire quelque part parfois on ironise sur
le Sénat et je dois avouer que j'imagine
une 6e
de quoi mais mais là ils font du bon
boulot parce que c'est très intéressant
tout ça et ça montre une espèce de
faillite des mensonges ou plus au niveau
de l'État c'est préoccupant quand vous
avez un ministre de l'Intérieur qui dit
des choses qui ne sont pas vérifiées que
vous avez un préfet d'allemand qui dit
lui-même c'est lui qui manifestant est à
l'origine de la fake news des 40000 faux
billets etc et que vous avez une
utilisation abusive des forces de
l'ordre moi j'ai une haute idée de ce
qu'est le métier de policier de force de
l'ordre mais ça fait trop de fois que
dans des événements publics comme ça
c'est la brutalité qui l'emporte c'est
ce sont des techniques de police qui
n’honorent pas la police républicaine
donc l'audition du Sénat à permet cela
et si nous sommes majoritaire évidemment
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura
on l'a fait et sur beaucoup d'autres
sujets et puis vous avez dit que j'ai
bien été élu mon ordre vous allez me
trouver extrêmement prétentieux que
c'est même moi qui a obtenu le meilleur
score national donc vous allez devant
vous le député le mieux élu de France
qui me rend mais je suis un petit peu
enflé mais non mais merci à cette belle
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est qui sont venus
voter pour nous et dimanche il faut
continuer à le faire merci Alexia merci
notre invité sur la porte
bon 20 secondes
on va regarder on va regarder la Une de
Ouest-France future majorité ce qui
inquiète le chef de l'État c'est à la
Une de Ouest-France merci beaucoup
Alexis Corbières et à très bientôt
[Musique]